Making movies is dangerous business, and making
exciting movies can be downright deadly.
It's not all special effects — there's real
danger that goes along with all of that big
screen magic.
Here's a look at a few famous movie scenes
that nearly killed actors.
Daniel Day-Lewis
Despite Daniel Day-Lewis's habit of putting
himself in danger for his roles, no stunts
were as dangerous as the pneumonia the actor
contracted on the set of Gangs of New York
after refusing to wear anything other than
his ragged 19th-century wardrobe coat, despite
frigid temperatures.
He also apparently fought random strangers
while filming in Rome just to keep in character
as the violent Bill the Butcher, who he described
to The Independent as,
"...a bit of a punk, a marvellous character
and a joy to be — but not so good for my
physical or mental health."
"A joy to be" is an interesting way to describe
getting your butt kicked by Italian randos.
But then again, we're talking about a guy
who spent three years getting punched in the
head to prepare for The Boxer by former champ
Barry McGuigan, so maybe everything he says
isn't going to make the most sense.
"I drink your milkshake!
Slllrrrppppp!"
Jennifer Lawrence
Accident-prone Jennifer Lawrence has a habit
of taking public spills, but it was no laughing
matter when a smoke machine malfunctioned
and almost suffocated her on the set of The
Hunger Games: Mockingjay – Part 1.
According to an insider on the set,
"Filming came to an abrupt halt when this
fog machine broke and began spewing so much
dense smoke during a tunnel sequence that
Jennifer literally disappeared from sight."
Luckily, she escaped with only a bit of vertigo
and nausea, but this wasn't the only time
The Hunger Games series knocked her around.
During training, she ran into a wall, sparking
rumors that she had damaged her spleen...
"Oh sorry, spleen juice."
...which turned out to be false.
But the next time everyone freaks out when
Lawrence asks to be paid the same as her male
costars, maybe we should all remember that
she's willing to bleed for our entertainment.
Joseph Gordon-Levitt
After safely starring in a Batman movie, a
time-traveling assassin movie, and a G.I.
Joe movie, Joseph Gordon-Levitt was almost
killed…while playing a bike messenger.
While 30 miles per hour might not sound too
fast, cruising between moving cars at that
speed on a bike is pretty serious.
A taxi drove over safety cones during filming
of Premium Rush and cut Gordon-Levitt off,
sending him through the rear windshield and
badly slicing up his forearm.
"Joe got the award for most stitches with
31 when he went through the back window of
a cab."
"It's funny how much attention you'll get
when there's some blood involved."
"This is Joe's bike, and that's where he ended
up."
Director David Koepp feared he was dead, and
later told MTV,
"And you're, ya know, for about 15 seconds
before I could get there and see what happened.
I'm thinking 'Did I kill him?
Did I actually kill an actor?'"
Gordon-Levitt actually laughed the whole thing
off, but we wonder if he thought it was so
funny when the movie's worldwide gross came
in $4 million below the production budget?
"Aah!"
"Aaaaahhhh!"
Jackie Chan
The list of Jackie Chan's endless on-set injuries
is basically a medical encyclopedia of busted
up body parts.
But his injury on the set of Armour of God
II was the worst of all.
Compared to some of the stuff he's done — like
sliding down the side of a skyscraper, and
getting hit by a real, flying helicopter — the
Armour of God II stunt was tame.
All he had to do was jump into a tree, but
he missed and fell to the ground, smacking
his head on a rock, which sent a piece of
his skull into his brain.
The injury required brain surgery, and a metal
plate implanted in Chan's skull.
Amazingly, this happened in the early '90s,
and Chan continued to make many more films,
performing almost all of his own stunts.
In other words, the exact opposite of what
any normal person would do.
But then, Jackie Chan isn't a normal person.
"I wanna be a Brontosaurus.
Agh difficult!"
Donald Sutherland
Most of the people on this list were badly
injured — and yes, could have been killed
in their on-set accidents — but none went
through quite the nightmare Donald Sutherland
endured.
Because he actually died.
On the set of Kelly's Heroes in 1968, Sutherland
contracted bacterial meningitis from the Danube
River and had an out-of-body experience.
His description of the incident is truly chilling.
"The downward journey slowed and stopped.
I'd been on my way to being dead when some
memory of the desperate rigor I'd applied
to survive all my childhood illnesses pulled
me back.
Forced me to live.
I was alive.
I'd come out of the coma.
Sick as a dog, but alive."
Both poetic and terrifying all at once.
Sutherland took over six weeks to recover,
at which point his contract forced him back
on screen, with his brain still fried, afraid
of water and heights, and — according to
him -- constantly weeping.
"Don't hit me with them negative waves so
early in the morning."
Jason Statham
Action star Jason Statham knew exactly what
to expect when Sylvester Stallone asked him
back for The Expendables 3...except for the
fact that he'd almost get drowned, blown up,
or crushed to death — whichever one of those
happens when you accidentally drive a truck
off a loading dock.
Something went wrong with the brakes in Statham's
vehicle, causing the truck to quickly plunge
60 feet.
But Statham, who once competed as an Olympic
diver, was able to get free.
"The survival sort of kicks in and you pull
yourself out of the window and you start grabbing
at the water and trying to get to the surface."
"Could you see anything?
Was it dark?"
"Ya, I mean they don't call it the Black Sea
for no reason."
Apparently, Sly was unconcerned.
"I look out and I say 'Where's Sly?' and he's,
ya know, stood on the side of dock there with
his iPhone, like that going 'Eh uh Jason,
ya need a towel?'"
"Hahaha"
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!